who's up next hi I'm Andrew all right
what do you do I'm a headhunter a
headhunter it sounds exciting when
people say it then you remember how
boring it is off you go with your story
okay so my fiancee is from the Czech
Republic and a big big tradition there
on Easter Monday and this is fact is the
the girl's big to get whipped where we
got these people where they vet it hello
who's there
hi hi our thanks very good thanks so now
oh now are you from the Sweden no I'm
not I'm from Northern Ireland oh really
I have a very good ear is live in Sweden
what what I used to live in Sweden for
six months see ya can you speak Swedish
I can say one one sentence is it
disgusting no okay go okay go ingen
rectum
oh say again you engine rattling tech it
means no junk mail please okay say that
again alarm okay yes I think this a is
your anyway I can't take anything
[Applause]
hello what's your name
Petra Petra and where you from Petra I'm
from Czech Republic
[Applause]
he's just like Happy Easter
watch you can sit down
it's true it's true we begging to be
whipped no no you you don't beg to be
whipped you betcha
on Easter Monday only on Easter Bunny
smile is a tradition that if you get
whipped on Easter Monday you will
remained beautiful and healthy for the
upcoming year or maybe she thought maybe
then I'll get it out of the way in the
one-day instr Tuesday suppose do you
have a story or you just read it oh your
daughter story off you go off you go
yeah so about three years ago my fiancee
and I we went to Paris for a romantic
weekend and at the hotel I realized I
don't have a toothbrush so I decided to
pop into the pharmacy while he was
waiting outside so I walked back out and
I said well you would be surprised but
French people actually I really know
it's impolite and he said well how come
and I said well if you show a bit of
effort and speak a little bit of French
instead of English they really
appreciate it and he said so what did
you say and I said well I walk in I said
Bonjour Monsieur
and she would lay and
[Applause]
let's even get a story hello nice lady
what's your name Jessica Jessica can
puke when you hear Jessica by then good
she's so sweet she's French she's
adorable
atomic she's French she said did she say
like pelo
[Applause]
okay can you ever go in the chair okay
go you go and do that again okay where's
the chair it took all of that man there
follow-up on his back okay this story
louder
oh well basically tonight was very
exciting for me because from the time I
was about 13 years old I used to have a
kind of fantasy or dream about mr.
Stallone being my father okay who's up
next
hi ru hi I just like to say that I think
Matt Damon is really amazing in the
fourth like one of those things okay
okay off you go
you didn't know yeah he was my husband
I'm one of three girls about ten years
ago I was on holiday in Dublin checking
into in Dublin International Airport a
my 11 year old sister starts watching
someone check in and she runs up to this
person and says oh my god are you man
Hathaway and then turns around whips off
her sunglasses and says hi you can call
me Annie and then you know proceeds to
interact and talk to all of us asking
how our holiday is posing pictures with
us it was so nice it was so lovely and
that would have been a really great
story had it ended there however left my
mother then just started crying
hysterically about how nice and Hathaway
was who naturally none of these people
had any context and naturally thought
she was batshit crazy for being so
lovely and nice and for
sorry okay so a few years ago I was
teaching in a class and we had the globe
sight and the children were discovering
all the new countries they'd never seen
before and a little boy points Italy
says what country is this and I said oh
that's Papua New Guinea
does anybody know why Papua New Guinea
is really famous
nobody knew so I said well they still
eat humans there it's really strange
right does anybody know what that is
when another human eats another human
and this little boy stuck his hand and
said yeah I know
lesbians Cumberbatch and I were actually
at the same boarding school we both went
to Harrow and there are lots of rumors
circulating about what he got up to
there
[Applause]
I've got your back you didn't only have
it
okay so I was driving home for Christmas
bringing back my grandparents my grandma
was in the back of the car and she gets
travel sick so we were driving along and
she was feeling really bad so we gave
her a plastic bag and she just stopped
you do that
[Laughter]
[Applause]
looking forward to this right this is
Thomas so which of you knows Thomas you
so what's your name
I'm Jessica Jessica why is Thomas upset
with us um Thomas is upset because I've
postponed a date for the second time so
I could come and be here you see your
boyfriend no no we have not been on a
date yes so you put him up why did you
put him off for the first time my sister
and this time Kylie's okay you know that
look not that into you can I suggest you
take him out tomorrow night when this is
on this story all about how my life got
flipped don't you dare
hello who's there hello sir hello what's
your name
Thomas okay and where are you from I'm
from Durham Durham alright but you live
here now yes okay very good
off you go with this story Thomas so I
asked a girl up a couple of weeks ago
and she said yes which was great because
she's quite hot and a little joke
[Applause]
you schedule
put on me in bed come here what style
I thought they'd come down as if she
wanted to rearrange for next week's a
covers your very key but she has given
you no indication that she didn't look
good thing is he didn't make other plans
that's good yeah okay so so this is your
decision now this is you this is you
sending a message to him so Jessica are
we going to flip Thomas
or we gonna let Thomas war okay Kylie
please we leave him off the red tab
[Applause]
literally dumped
[Music]
you